We said the Trusted Computing Base
has direct access to the hardware.
Hardware, we said, we can trust,
that's not something we're going to,
although you may have reasons to, to,
be suspicious, of hardware itself, but
we're not going to go there, so
we're basically talking about
how can we trust software.
The software is supposed to perform,
a set of functions.
We've been discussing some of those,
whether in a recently accessed control,
or kind of policies that
are supported and so on.
So if it's going to implement
certain functionality,
it has to be functionally correct.
Okay, when it says it
implements a certain model,
it implements that model correctly.
The functional correctness
basically means
that it does what it was designed to do.
So it implements a set of functions and
that is done correctly.
Now, to implement those functions,
it does have data structure.
So data state that it makes use of.
Also, it may be protecting other data
that belongs to different users and
programs, and things like that.
If it's trusted software,
we wanted to implement the function
it's supposed to do correctly,
as well as maintain And the integrity of
that data that it is going to rely on.
And we want it to maintain that
integrity even in the presence of
bad input.
Okay, so we do explore some interface or
API, hence the bad guys can try to use
it in ways that we didn't expect it to
be used, give it bad input for example.
So the integrity that should be
maintained by the trusted computing base
actually is maintained in
the presence of a correct model, but
an adversity may even try
to provide bad input.
Obviously, there is sensitive data
that it uses and it protects for
other users and applications.
It has to address the confidentiality or
disclosure of this sensitive data,
it shouldn't be disclosed to somebody
who doesn't have access to it.
And it should do that in the presence
of un-trusted software obviously.
We're not going to assume that all
software is going to be trusted.
Okay, so
we have our trusted computing base and
then untrusted software that
is run by applications so on.
So this disclosure that
we want to control for
sensitive data can make assumption that
all code is the system is trusted.
So the last couple of requirements
we identified in terms of integrity,
confidentiality, implementing the
necessary functions really talk about
what it does.
Our confidence basically says
how well does it do that?
Okay.
Confidence,
we can't demand a proof that's going
to be really hard, a formal proof.
But, as we said earlier there could be
things that increase our confidence
in the system's ability to do all
these things that we're talking about.
So where does this confidence come from?
Well, a lot of things in real life,
it could come from the fact
there experts of these kind of stuff and
evaluating this kind of a system.
And maybe they analyze it,
they spend time with it.
And it's their word based on which we
actually derive our confidence and
the trust that is assured by the system.
Finally, we can think about
this as our requirements or
needs, in terms of trustworthiness,
can be maybe captured in a statement.
And that statement says, well, this is
the kind of security or trust we expect
the system to provide, or this is
what we expect the system to enforce.
And then the system, someone who
builds the system, design and
builds the system.
So let's say there's a vendor
who provides the system.
We said TCB functionality,
normally operating system is where it
goes in typical systems that we have, so
an OS vendor, for example, may have to
then tell us our requirements are met.
We come with some sort of
a requirements analysis, or
a statement that sort of
captures our expectation.
And then somebody has to
give us a checklist or
a proof of some kind that allows us to
believe that our expectations are met.
And so the best possible scenario is
that all this could be done formally.
We actually have a proof that
whoever is providing the trusted
computing base actually
meets our requirements,
our expectations that we
capture in this statement.
When we have formal proof of it,
that would be ideal, but
would it be possible always?
This is one of the questions we're going
to explore as we go through this lesson.